vamos a contar juntos de 0 a 19 0 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 y ahora vamos a los números
de 2 dígitos 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
y 19 porque hice esto lo que quiero es
que veamos un patrón especialmente en
esta columna de números de dos dígitos
lo que podemos encontrar es que todos
empiezan con 1 el primer dígito es uno y
este uno está en lo que llamamos la
posición de las decenas y todos estos
números tienen un 1 que representa una
decena y que quiero decir con esto si
vamos al 10 que tenemos aquí nos dice
que este 1 representa 10 y que este 0
representa a 0 unidades así que diese es
igual a 10 más
y van a decir que descubrimientos y ya
sabemos que si sumamos 0 cualquier
número el resultado es ese número pero
vemos que este patrón se repite en todos
los números que tenemos aquí así que en
el número 11 este uno amarillo es igual
a 10 y este una rosa es igual a 1 y
vamos con el 12 este 1 amarillo
representa 10 y este 2 rosa
representados también podemos verlo como
una decena o un grupo de 10 y este 2 son
2 unidades por eso tenemos 2 aquí y
podemos seguir creo que ya pueden ver el
patrón este 1 representa 10 + 3 13 es
igual a 10 3 14
es igual a 10
+ 4
15 es igual a 10 más 5 y los invito a
que pasen el vídeo y traten de terminar
lo que falta traten de escribir 16 17 18
y 19 como 10 más otro número pero deben
estar seguros de que entienden lo que
está pasando hagámoslo 16 es igual a 10
bueno puedes escribir todos los que
faltan como diez más algo
10 16 es 10 617 es 10 718 es 10 + 8 y 19
10 9 y cuando escribimos los números de
esta manera se vuelve muy claro que este
1 en cada número representa 10 y el
dígito de la derecha representa las
unidades